[Music]
once everything was awesome
now everything is okay Lucy I brought
you coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark times oh my gosh did
I interrupt you brooding just now times
have changed you need to change with
them we have to be tough and
battle-ready
Oh
hurry the door is slowly closing
oh hey it's Kane so cold see that wasn't
so bad nothing got in
[Applause]
[Music]
save your life I don't get it we'll help
me rescue my friends go anywhere near
that sistar system it's ruled by an
alien coin only the toughest you're
gonna get out of there alive I'm a queen
whatever I would not be I'm getting
super evil vibes here I could change my
form to something else if this makes you
uncomfortable hey guys
he'll go back don't worst was much more
palatable double dots on your face
who are you I'm your worst nightmare me
when I'm late to school and I forgot my
homework and my pants are made of
pudding
no I don't holidays in Apokolips
the weather is dusty and the copy tastes
extra pumpkin spicy this holiday season
has definitely send it into chaos now
that if a DUPLO savages destroyed our
land hey Lucy happy holidays sorry did I
interrupt your brooding sesh
oh yeah it's no biggie I was just
filling everyone in and have tough it is
to live here but you know it'll cheer
everyone up please don't say holiday
party you said it no yes no ah come on
I've got a plan step one get everyone
together in the town square
step two ice skating step three decorate
this town for the most tinsel tastic
holiday party apocalypse burg has ever
seen here who be captaining this Holly
Jolly Mary Mary
lower section 12 we need more green
bricks let's go let go Lucy this tree
lights up you'll be able to see it from
we don't need any more unwanted
attention relax just think this is a
quite little neighborhood shindig with
just a few of our closest friends in a
tree you may or may not be able to
however you celebrate let's celebrate to
gather more eggnog huh mmm I wait all
year for this sweet nectar of joy
indubitably to light it up kid
there she closed
I like darkness this is it super
beautiful
[Music]
looks like it's Anup eighties apocalypse
burgers of visit yes
I mean oh no I knew it
everyone fatal Stan I was not expecting
that
[Music]
Alfred is sweater only has eight abs now
cool bro but Sir knowed me are you hello
visitors from another planet there's no
need to fight anymore see friends they
took Lucy and the others hang on to your
Franz plan
you mind if I save your life not at all
Rex danger vest this is my dinosaur
space aliens kidnapped my friends I'm
going to the talking horse I could
change my form but this makes you
uncomfortable hey guys no go back don't
worry is much more palatable come with
me on this adventure to save my friends
teach me to be tough let's go find your
friends different did you draw double
dots on your face
[Music]
sorry
banana keeps slipping on his field on
the way out you gone bruised open you
almost forgot me guys I'm literally a
lantern how did you miss me a lifetime
has passed since the horrific events of
Taco Tuesday our lives descended into
chaos this new life has toughened and
hardened
two copies please one black one with
just a touch of cream in 25 sugars
well nothing most of us I wake up in the
morning morning good morning super
babies Amit you've got to stop
pretending everything is awesome
it isn't yeah I get it and that's why
I've cultivated a totally hard-edged
side that's super tough and
what is it up to but that beat is pretty
fresh
[Music]
[Music]
it's like it knows our every move weird
right this guy was a fierce warrior
okay well technically I did the warrior
stuff so you fought masterbuilt and
kicked butt and then the hapless male
was the leader here well
[Music]
hang on to your fronds planning we're
going to save Lucy and all of the other
people who were captured
[Music]
behold the star system do not give her
the satisfaction of wooing this
[Music]